okay now here's where things start to
get interesting remember bloodborne
system that allowed you to attack
shortly after getting hit and regain
some of your health Liza P has a very
similar system in place but with a Twist
you'll only be able to regain a portion
of the health back if you're blocking so
if you take a hit without blocking you
can't regain any of that Health back by
attacking you'll have to heal normally
oh and did I also mention the enemies
they can do this too in fact they don't
even have to attack you to start
regaining some of their health that's
right every enemy in the game and it
really encourages you to stay aggressive
so you're not just gonna run off and
hide in the corner now I feel like this
is balanced out by not giving the enemy
the ability to fully heal at least the
enemies that I encountered in the game
and you'll be able to tell by looking at
that section that's sort of grayed out
now to add a further wrinkle to this the
game also has a parrying system so if
you manage to time your block at just
the right moment you'll block 100 of the
attack and not take any damage at all